So Jeffrey Epstein, the alleged sex trafficker
who was accused of course, along with Donald
Trump
raping a 13 year old girl was found dead in
his jail cell of what's being called an apparent
suicide.
And of course the conspiracy theory surrounding
his death predictably and just instantly exploding
a disclaimer once again, this story in all
of the ones related to it or last week's shootings
and all of this stuff will be fully demonetized
by youtube as they have been, uh, for the
entire week.
Consider supporting the work we do directly
because Youtube has determined that all of
these stories are not add or brand safe.
Uh, Epstein was arrested and awaiting trial
on charges of sexually abusing dozens of young
girls.
Epstein had been put on suicide watch after
being found with what seemed to be a self
inflicted wound then was taken off of Suicide
Watch 12 days before he was found hanged in
his cell.
Why he was taken off of suicide watch is currently
unclear.
That's becoming part of the conspiracies surrounding
the conspiracy theories surrounding this.
And, um, the, I mean we have to start sort
of unpacking it with the logic of the conspiracist.
Uh, one of the ideas is he was taken off of
suicide watch so that he would kill himself
or it wasn't really suicide.
He was taken off of suicide watch to create
a cover for someone to murder him and then
for it to be called a suicide because he was
taken off of suicide watch anyway, one way
or the other.
Immediately a whole bunch of elected officials
won an investigation.
This includes senators, this includes Donald
Trump's attorney general, William Barr and
others.
And of course Trump's justice department being
the department that will now carry forward
whatever investigation is going to take place
is extraordinarily problematic according to
many because of the connections between Epstein
and Trump in and of themselves.
Now I have to tell you the main conspiracy
sort of doesn't make it that much sense in
terms of motive, given that it is much more
complex than the simplest murder hypothesis
that exists.
Or let me put it a different way.
The idea is Epstein was about to pull Trump
into the mess documents might show that Epstein
was recruiting young girls at Mar-a-lago,
or there might've been something revealed
related to the girl that Epstein allegedly
raped who was also allegedly raped by Donald
Trump when she was 13 years old at the Manhattan
Condo of Jeffrey Epstein's.
So the idea is let's silence him.
Let's arrange for him to be killed.
But step back for just one second.
Believed child abusers are not treated well
in prisons and jails.
They are some of the primary targets of violence
outside of gang-related violence in jails
and prisons.
If you want to go in the direction of this
wasn't suicide, it was murder, which by the
way, I'm open to, I'm not dismissing this
by any means.
You don't actually need to go to, it was a
political murder involving Trump or whoever
else.
Child sex abusers are targeted in the prison
system and it requires far fewer explanations
and assumptions other than why was he taken
off of suicide watch if indeed that is part
of the entire circumstance.
Now, of course immediately people are coming
up with conspiracy theories that make no sense
for me.
If you say, imagine this wasn't a suicide
and it was a murder, who is most likely to
have done it?
Let's explore that.
I've already said, if you look at a history
of how this works in prisons, people in the
prison system who go after child molesters
would be like the number one culprits in my
mind.
Second, it would be something related to Trump
or mar-a-lago because of those connections,
but right wingers heard about this apparent
suicide and immediately said, oh, it's related
to dems or Hilary or something related to
pizza gate or Bill Clinton was once in a picture
with Jeffrey Epstein.
This is another Clinton body count person
or whatever.
Epstein was super rich.
Everyone in power knew him.
Pictured with Bill Clinton pictured in many
pictures with Donald Trump, but we have specific
allegations that Donald Trump raped a girl
that Epstein also raped at Epstein's Manhattan
Condo.
If we are simply theorizing, I have no idea
why you go to the Clinton's before you go
to Trump.
Not to mention Trump has a long history of
centralizing his own daughter.
He's on video with Epstein evaluating the
attractiveness of girls at a party.
And by the way, if Bill Clinton or the Clintons
in general are so powerful as these conspiracy
theories require them or imply them to be,
why weren't they able to just manipulate things
and get Hillary Clinton elected?
That is not one that they will often answer.
Uh, one idea that's been floated, uh, is Epstein
staged the first suicide attempt.
In other words, the first suicide attempt
was not really a suicide attempt.
It was Epstein knowing that he was potentially
in danger doing something to get himself put
on suicide watch.
And that, that wasn't enough.
That's another idea.
Genuinely, I have no idea what happened, but
I was not shocked when over the weekend I
heard that he was found dead in his cell.
I want to hear from you.
What do you think happened here?
Let me know.
And ideally maybe try to support it with some
evidence.